[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrige serien ihnen einen schönen
samstagabend sportliches gibt's wieder
mit kristin otto mit tollen erfolgen
genannt auch heute müssen wir den fokus
auf den krieg gegen
bilder der zerstörung mario pohl in der
ukraine liegt in trümmern aus mehreren
städten werden menschen über flucht
korridore evakuiert
suche nach neuen energielieferanten
wirtschaftsminister habe kreis nach
katar und bemüht sich um neue
gasverträge
und sensationeller sieg zum karriere
ende biathlet erik lesser gewinnt die
verfolgung beim weltcup finale in oslo
ja wieder schwere angriffe und gefechte
mit toten und verletzten und weiterhin
massive fluchtbewegungen aus den
umkämpften gebieten
informationen lassen sich nach wie vor
schwer unabhängig überprüfen moskau
meldet den einsatz einer hyperschall
rakete einer waffe die putin als
unbesiegbar bezeichnet über den 24 tag
des krieges in der ukraine
thomas garcia und alexandra schenk
unter schweren beton ein zerbrechliches
leben helfer in brake versuchen ein
kleinkind zu retten die twitter bilder
nicht nachprüfbar es heißt der kleine
junge habe nicht überlebt
überall in der ukraine angriffe die auch
kinder treffen die kleinsten werden in
diesem krieg nicht verschont auch von
dieser waffe wird das land nun
heimgesucht kind alleine neue rakete
schneller als der schall hier von
russland in szene gesetzt und laut
moskau erstmals auf die ukraine
abgefeuert das ziel ganz im westen im
dorf the latin 100 kilometer vom nato
mitglied rumänien entfernt das kind
schall raketensystem hat ein großes
unterirdisches depot der ukrainischen
streitkräfte zerstört das raketen und
munition enthielt
auf deutsch deutlich treffsicher aus
1000 kilometern 6000 km h schnell eine
bedrohung mit eskalationspotenzial
so experten die raketen sind im moment
für die luftverteidigungssysteme zu
schnell und die flugzeuge diese
abschießen sind außerhalb der reichweite
der gegenwärtig gegenwärtigen
luftverteidigungssysteme die gefährliche
waffe eingesetzt nachdem russlands forma
stockte heute auch dass die ukrainische
zugang zum meer abgeschnitten und kiew
gibt zu mario pohl können nicht auf
hilfe hoffen der feind der die zerbombte
ausgebrannte metropole umlagert einfach
zu mächtig
immerhin zivilisten schafften es erneut
raus über einen flucht korridor einige
gelangten sogar bis ins westliche
lemberg
und charkiw in der zerstörten stadt auch
dies er hat meine taschenlampe gesehen
ist anderthalb meter weg sagt der helfer
dann hätten sie diesen mann aus den
trümmern in all dem leid ein lichtblick
ein kleiner
in der südukrainischen hafenstadt odessa
ist katrin eigendorf für uns katrina
soll schwere gefechte vor odessa gegeben
haben was können sie uns darüber sagen
ja in der stadt nikolaev die ungefähr
120 kilometer von hier entfernt ist wird
ja seit tagen sehr sehr schwer gekämpft
zwischen russischer und ukrainischer
armee und hier nur deshalb sagt man wenn
nikolai feldern ist im prinzip die
bedrohung so deshalb um vielfaches
größer ist hat es heute da einen
schweren angriff gegeben auf eine
soldaten unterkünfte sind über 200
soldaten nach bisherigen informationen
des gouverneurs ums leben gekommen das
macht den leuten natürlich hier sorge
und angst und wir haben heute auch jetzt
zum zweiten mal hier luftalarm der wurde
gerade gerade wurde entwarnung gegeben
die sorge wächst natürlich hier das sich
auch in odessa die situation
dramatischer zuspitzt aber im prinzip
weiß man nirgendwo in der ukraine im
moment wo russland zu schlagen kann das
verunsichert natürlich die menschen
überall im land enorm dankeschön nach
odessa katrin eigendorf
dieser krieg produziert unzählige
tragödien die noch jahrzehnte nachhallen
werden auch in den köpfen der
allerkleinsten die überhaupt nicht
begreifen können warum bomben fallen
menschen sterben familien sich
vielleicht nie wieder sehen und einige
trifft es doppelt hart mein kollege dara
hassanzadeh berichtet aus dem
westukrainischen lemberg
die krebsstation des kinderkrankenhaus
in lemberg die kinder kommen aus
historischer oder kiew hinter ihnen
liegt eine flucht die sie mit ihrer
krankheit durchstehen mussten
ich bin erleichtert ihr schläft mein
kind ruhig es hat keine angst aber es
ist immer noch krieg in meinem land
meine verwandten unser zuhause ich weiß
nicht wohin wir zurückkehren sollen
die kinderklinik in lemberg ist nur
zwischenstation es fehlt ein nuklear
medizinisches zentrum für krebstherapien
davon gibt es nur zwei in der ukraine
beide im umkämpften kiew
wir können die kinder intensiv
medizinisch betreuen und ihren zustand
stabilisieren und erst wenn die kinder
stabil sind schicken wir sie nach polen
für diese krankentransporte gibt es
keine grenzkontrollen und keine
wartezeiten polen und die ukraine haben
sich abgestimmt
dort gibt es sehr gute ärzte und
kliniken aber sein land zu verlassen ist
immer traurig ich wünsche mir dass alle
kinder die reise gut überstehen heute
das oxidiert geburtstage
ein letztes interview vor der abfahrt
wir haben keine zeit mehr wir müssen los
die väter bleiben zurück männer zwischen
18 und 60 jahren dürfen nicht aus der
ukraine ausreisen
trotz abschiedsschmerz was für eine
erleichterung bei all jenen die es
geschafft haben dem inferno zu
entfliehen offiziell sind inzwischen
über 200.000 geflüchtete in deutschland
angekommen empfangen werden sie herzlich
aber es gibt gleich ein großes problem
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer können ihre
landeswährung nämlich in den banken der
euro länder nicht umtauschen über das
problem und die folgen susanna santino
vor ihrer flucht aus der ukraine mussten
olver ihre freundinnen und ihre kinder
zuletzt fünfmal am tag im
luftschutzkeller verbringen sie sind
dankbar dass sie im hessischen raunheim
in sicherheit sind schlitz sana rizzo
hatte ihn die wohnung organisiert in der
sie kostenlos leben können zum glück
sagen sie denn ihr bargeld konnten sie
nicht umtauschen
ich war bei der sparkasse und habe
gefragt gibt es eine möglichkeit unser
geld in euro umzutauschen
sie haben gesagt nein alle ukraine die
ich gefragt habe haben überall dieselbe
erfahrung gemacht
viele menschen aus der ukraine hatten
vor der flucht ihr geld von ihren konten
abgehoben weil sie nicht wussten was
damit passiert wenn die russen ihre
stadt einnehmen sollten bargeld schien
ihnen sicherer ist jetzt aber in keinem
der euro-staaten umtauschbar von der
europäischen zentralbank heißt es
gegenüber dem zdf dazu wir sind uns der
ernsthaftigkeit dieses problems bewusst
auf europäischer ebene werden mögliche
lösungen geprüft um ukrainischen
flüchtlingen beim umtausch ihrer währung
zu helfen ein massiver umtausch der
ukrainischen währung könnte für banken
hohe verluste bedeuten denn es gibt zu
wenig nachfrage nach der griffner und zu
hohe ausfallrisiken der finanzminister
betont dass die euro-staaten mit der ezb
im gespräch seien technisch und
finanziell ist das
nicht trivial
politisch ist es gewünscht den menschen
zu helfen das hoffen auf olver und ihre
freundinnen eigentlich hätten sie genug
geld sagen sie da sie es nicht nutzen
können seien sie aber mittellos und
wenn sie die flüchtlinge unterstützen
möchten so können sie spenden über das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine
nachzulesen alles auch auf spenden punkt
zdf.de oder auf der zdf textseite 890
sie wissen deutschland ist abhängig von
russischem gas das will die
bundesregierung jetzt möglichst schnell
ändern über die hälfte des gases nämlich
55 prozent beziehen wir aus russland
zweitgrößter lieferant ist norwegen mit
rund 30 prozent dorthin reiste
wirtschaftsminister habeck am mittwoch
um über weitere lieferungen zu
verhandeln und heute führte ihn seine
reise in den golfstaat katar simon
pfanzelt
scheichs stadt putin wirtschaftsminister
habeck ist auf der suche nach energie
alternativen heute in doha ziel der
reise ist mittelfristig eine wasserstoff
partnerschaft aufzubauen und kurzfristig
fördermöglichkeiten auszuloten
flüssiggas kurz lng es soll die
energieversorgung in deutschland in den
nächsten jahren sicherstellen katar ist
einer der größten exporteure
allerdings wäre deutschland auf seinen
nachbarn angewiesen um das gas nutzen zu
können überall in europa gibt es termin
ist für lng in deutschland bislang nicht
planung und bau dauern jahre doch die
bundesregierung steht unter druck der
besuch ist offensichtlich notwendig weil
wir uns zu sehr auf russland als
lieferant verlassen haben und deswegen
jetzt umsteuern müssen katar springt er
als lückenbüßer ein wird sich das teuer
bezahlen lassen hat interesse an langen
verträgen und das ist eben der preis der
verschleppten energiewende
unabhängig werden von russischem gas auf
diesem weg gibt es viele baustellen für
robert habeck
auch in belgien sorgt man sich wegen des
krieges um die energieversorgung die
regierung will deshalb den geplanten
atomausstieg verschieben das
kernkraftwerk teams drei nahe der
deutschen grenze und ein reaktor bei
antwerpen sollen bis 2035 weiterlaufen
bundespräsident steinmeier ist aus
schloss bellevue ausgezogen allerdings
nur vorübergehend für kurze zeit
verlegte er seinen amtssitz ins
thüringische altenburg um mehr
tuchfühlung zu den bürgern und der
kommunalpolitik aufzubauen mehr von
melanie haack und johanna kießler
die zweite amtszeit beginnt beim
frühstück mit ehrenamtlich engagierten
altenburgern
[Musik]
ein austausch über viele themen
fachkräftemangel corona stärkung des
ehrenamts das bewegt sie hier und
schlichtweg mehr aufmerksamkeit für ihre
region sind die schärfe ragenden uns
bürgern beschleicht immer mal das gefühl
die da oben wir da unten und auch die
wie ferner zu den problemen mit
uns als partner masse raus aus schloss
bellevue rein ins land ran an die
menschen für drei tage hat frank walter
steinmeier seinen amtssitz hierher
verlegt der oberbürgermeister nennt die
aufgaben beim namen er selbst war
zuletzt drohungen durch gegner der
korona maßnahmen ausgesetzt das ist die
große politik versteht dass der
ländliche raum ganz andere aufgaben und
not und sorgen hat als große
ballungsgebiete und das gesetzlich
darauf hingearbeitet wird das haus hätte
beleidigung in den sozialen medien dass
dort irgendwie versucht wird dem
ranzugehen steinmeier will zuhören zu
sehen und den dialog suchen auch in
kontroversen gesprächen demokratie ist
und irgendwo vom himmel gefallen nicht
in deutschland nicht anderswo und sie
bleibt auch nicht auf ewig garantiert
sondern demokratie lebt davon dass sich
menschen für sie engagieren und dann
geht es weiter zum nächsten termin vor
ort in altenburg
anfang des monats hatte österreich seine
corinna beschränkungen weitgehend
aufgehoben aber weil die
infektionszahlen steigen gelten ab mitte
nächster woche schärfere maßnahmen in
öffentlichen innenräumen müssen alle
wieder ffp zwei maske tragen auch in
deutschland steigen die zahlen das
robert koch institut meldete
260.000 239 neue fälle binnen 24 stunden
23.000 153 mehr als vor einer woche
außerdem kamen 2 121 todesfälle hinzu
die sieben tage incidents liegt nun bei
trotz hoher zahlen sollen bei uns ja
morgen viele corona maßnahmen wegfallen
so steht es im neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz wogegen viele
bundesländer vergeblich protestierten
allerdings dürfen sie die bisherigen
noch zwei wochen verlängern bernd
mosebach berichtet aus hamburg und
mecklenburg vorpommern
nun also doch nicht eigentlich hatte
angelika leonhard gehofft dass jetzt
gelockert wird doch mecklenburg
vorpommern bleibt dabei die strengen
schutz maßnahmen gelten mindestens bis
zum zweiten april ihr café in schwerin
hat sie mit müh und not durch die krise
gebracht die nächsten zwei wochen sagt
sie wird sie auch noch durchstehen
da habe ich kein verständnis
dann können sie genauso sagen wir machen
lokale zu aber wenn man jetzt sagt okay
das bleibt maske und 3g und mit test das
finde ich jetzt in ordnung
möglicherweise werden die maßnahmen
sogar über den zweiten april hinaus
verlängert die landesregierung prüft
gerade ob das rechtlich möglich ist denn
die fallzahlen sind explodiert das land
steht bundesweit derzeit an der spitze
und das merken wir in der klinik auch an
der uni medizin kreisweit haben wir im
pflegebereich zum beispiel aktuell 20
prozent der mitarbeiter die ausfallen in
einzelnen kliniken sind bis zu 40
prozent und das wird sich sofort aus auf
die anzahl betreiber arbeiten die
bundesweit niedrigste sieben tage
inzidenz verzeichnet gerade das
nachbarland hamburg doch auch für
einzelhändlerin sabine falkenhagen und
ihre kundschaft ändert sich erstmal
nichts auch hier werden die
schutzmaßnahmen bis zum 2 april
verlängert für hamburg ist es gut weil
die schulferien jetzt zu ende sind und
wenn man weiß ja aus erfahrungen dass
die schulferien das ende immer auch ein
kleiner hotspot ist und dass die
zahnstein der bund hat die verantwortung
für den chor ohne schutz weitgehend den
ländern übertragen und die bleiben erst
mal vorsichtig
wir machen jetzt sportlich weiter mit
kristin es gab ein jahr quasi
unglaublichen triumph von ihre gläser
bier tlo ich finde es richtig cool wenn
es am schönsten ist sollte man aufhören
fast eine punktlandung für erik lesser
mit einer erstaunlichen energieleistung
zum weltcup triumph ein überragender
vorletzte auftritt des 33 jährigen und
das sein legendärer stelle in oslo nein
geschenkt ist erfolg nicht für erik
lesser märchenhaft fast kitschig beim
vorletzten rennen seiner karriere beim
könig harald für ein zelt zu stehen was
wollen wissen hat mir gratuliert und das
ein riesen fan von mir ist
zwei schießfehler beim führenden
norweger la geräte die tür geht auf
lässt ist fehlerfrei läuft tagesbestzeit
wie mich auch wichtig zu sehen dass er
auf der höhe des geschehens abtritt und
nicht irgendwie um platz 50 rumläuft der
dritte weltcupsieg seiner karriere der
erste nach sechs jahren sensationell das
laser märchen in oslo
und fast märchenhaft auch das saisonende
für lena dürr beim weltcup finale der
alpinen im französischen mary bell
belegte sie rang zwei in ihrer
spezialdisziplin dem slalom hinter der
slowenin andreas loca und verbuchte
damit ihr bestes resultat dieses olympia
winters
große freude auch bei snowboarderin
ramona hofmeister sie hat zum dritten
mal nacheinander den gesamtweltcup
gewonnen dafür reichte hier im
parallelslalom beim heimrennen in
berchtesgarden platz 3 im kleinen finale
gewannen sie gegen die österreicherin
daniela obing tagessiegerin die zog aus
der schweiz
am tag nach dem abbruch des fußball
bundesligaspiels zwischen bochum und
borussia mönchengladbach wegen des
bierbecherwurfs auf einen schiedsrichter
assistenten hat der
dfb-kontrollausschuss die ermittlungen
aufgenommen dabei geht es um die
spielwertung und das strafverfahren
gegen den vfl jetzt zu den ergebnissen
geführt freiburg 0 0 lichtblick für
hertha bsc 13 uhr gegen hoffenheim mainz
bielefeld 40 stuttgart augsburg 3 zu 2
ausführlich zum topspiel bayern münchen
union berlin im aktuellen sportstudio
bochum gladbach wie eben erwähnt gestern
abend abgebrochen
morgen beschließen drei partien den 27
spieltag die obere tabellenhälfte bisher
mit wenig aussagekraft freiburg und
hoffenheim haben es verpasst noch höher
zu rücken der sc vorerst vierter
hoffenheim bleibt sechster enge am
tabellenende stuttgart und härter im
leichten aufwärtstrend zu bielefeld
runter auf den abstiegsplatz vor
greuther fürth und mehr wie gewohnt im
sportstudio 23 uhr 5
sie wissen auf der erde stehen sich
russland und der westen erbittert
gegenüber anders sieht's im weltraum aus
auf der internationalen raumstation iss
sind jetzt drei russische kosmonauten
angekommen eine außerordentlich
herzliche begrüßung auch von den
amerikanischen co mitgliedern und dem
deutschen matthias maurer das schade
dass es nicht auch hier auf der erde so
läuft morgen ist kalendarischer
frühlingsanfang warum das nacht wetter
dazu so gar nicht passt erfahren sie
gleich von katja honnefer einschalten um
21.45 lohnt sich marietta slomka
erwartet sie zum heute-journal von uns
für sie einen schönen samstag und wir
sehen uns dann morgen wieder wenn sie
mir bis dahin
[Musik]
guten abend neben sonnenschein und
ostwind gab es heute auch kräftige
schauer das waren zum teil schneeschauer
wie im erzgebirge eigentlich eher
ungewöhnlich wir haben es doch mit einem
hoch zu tun aber eben auch mit einem
kaltluft tropfen das sehen sie hier in
der blauen farbe und dieser kaltluft
tropfen sieht morgen weiter in richtung
london heute nacht sorgte erst mal dafür
dass diese schauer nicht weiter richtung
westen und südwesten ziehen sondern
richtung nordwesten und so kann es noch
mal schneien im odenwald im taunus im
westerwald später in der eifel und im
schwarzwald
nordöstlich von ems weser und thüringer
wald ist es dagegen klar und über der
nordsee pfeift ein stürmischer wind aus
ost es wird kalt die temperaturen sinken
auf plus 3 bis minus 4 grad und liegen
morgen zwischen 8 grad auf rügen und 18
grad am oberrhein oder auch am neckar
morgen über tag fällt dann kein schnee
mehr es ist allenfalls regen und sie
sehen das meiste passiert auch westlich
der deutschen grenzen und so ist es
morgen sehr sonnig von nordfriesland bis
zum alpenrand und es wird immer noch ein
kräftiger wind meist aus ost die neue
woche startet mit viel sonne bei 10 bis
20 grad und einer großen waldbrandgefahr
im nordosten schönes wochenende